let's now go to that story of a man of
God who was allegedly caught in the act
one stupid mistake I've let down a lot
of people that's the bottom line
in the past few days I've begun to atone
for my private failings
the bustopher is said to have been found
in band with a woman believed to have
exchanged messages and photos of an
explicit nature with about six women
over the last three years there's no
question that I've done wrong and I take
full responsibility I did not have
sexual relations with that woman
some they can peace be with you we have
a crisis on our hands
infidelity adultery fornication it is
rampant
there's a statement attributed to
Salahuddin oub who says that if you want
to destroy a nation go ahead and make
adultery and fornication and wrap it and
that's what we're seeing today we're
seeing it prevalent all over it's even
affecting the Muslims and we are
supposed to be people at the highest
level of morality keeping a chase
keeping it real in marriage so what's
the solution
we also have a staggering amount of
sisters women who are complaining
because the Imams are not advocating for
them to help get them married and you
have men who are more than capable
enough financially physically to take
care of these women in Islam provides a
solution so we're here with an attorney
and a share to talk about this crisis
and to offer some solutions we'll be
right back
this is the this is the angel this is
the back here on the DS show and we have
two not one but two special guests we
have attorney-at-law
Hamid yes and we have shaked no stranger
to the Deen show mister [ __ ] Dean of
Academic Affairs at college of Islam
California Islamic University how long
you've been a practicing law since 2000
since 2000 we have a crisis right I was
in Florida about a year ago and mom came
up to me said look you know it's
something you need to talk about I have
sisters coming up to me and they're
telling me there there's no there is a
lack of Muslim men hoarse step up some
of these women are divorced some of them
have have been kind of you know put to
the side because maybe they have a child
they're divorced my widowed and nobody's
stepping up to marry these women but
there's people from other faith groups
who are trying to marry him what do we
do it's a catastrophe we also have a
epidemic of infidelity of adultery we
have an attorney and Islamic scholar how
we gonna solve this issue I mean this is
something that we really need to look
into and say okay when it comes to the
idea of women not being able to get
married this is a major problem late 20s
early 30s or even late 30s they get
divorced the way in which the community
is dealing with with many of these women
is they don't want to they don't want to
marry them and how do you how do you
convince people to kind of change their
their likes or their dislikes or change
their culture or something it's not
something easy to do so one of the
things I think we do need to consider at
least explore the possibility and it's
so controversial to even say it I mean
you bring it up and people are like I
can't believe you said that one of the
things we should consider is there are
many women especially divorced women
women who are unable to get married
they they're more likely to marry
someone or become someone's second wife
than as their only wife and that's an
avenue which we should actually consider
exploring the idea of polygyny or the
idea of having a second wife or having a
third wife or something like that which
is technically permissible in Islam but
it's something which a lot of people are
it's like a taboo now you can't even
talk about it you can't bring it up
people sort of tacking you Islamophobia
all that stuff let's hope you have an
attorney here to give us some legal
advice can you even talk about it sure
and my for my own experience is that
when people are concerned about polygamy
or polygyny especially the idea of
getting into that I don't necessarily
think many people at least not in my
community they're not necessarily as
concerned about the law or about their
job they're mostly concerned about their
standing in the community particularly
the Muslim community and and there's
this there is a stigma associated with
it and I think a lot of times people
might say something like the law of the
land or the law that doesn't prevent it
and it's true that bigamy is actually
not permitted in any state it's it's
against the law it's a criminal it's a
it's it's a it's criminally proscribed
and bigamy is the act of somebody who's
married getting married again and and
that is of course that is of course not
not permitted under the state law of any
state
however marriage in Islam and marriage
as exists under state law are two
completely different things in many ways
not merely the fact that you can marry
are men can marry more than one life
there are there are certainly there are
certainly many many other aspects to the
definition of marriage how you get
married how you get divorced that are
fundamentally different and and and the
social purpose behind marriage might be
might be not exactly the same and so so
those are those are also things that
that you need to consider marriage under
state law generally means and
there are there are going to be some
exceptions in some states but generally
means you have to go get a marriage
license and you have to you have to
follow you have to follow a particular
kind type of process for the state to
actually bless your marriage right for
the state sanction you are say that
you're your husband and wife under the
law there aren't a few states left very
few in the United States and this is
where it might be somewhat of a problem
for some Muslims legally is that there
are some states that recognize
common-law marriage common-law marriage
is this notion that man and a woman can
live together as husband and wife they
just they just publicize to the
community that you know we're married
they don't necessarily get the state's
permission and they would be regarded as
being married and and so that's that's
going to be one of the major pitfalls is
that you know if you have a you're
representing to the rest of the world
that you're married and one to one to
one person then you're doing the same
thing with another person in the vast
majority of the country that that
particular issue isn't going to be isn't
going to be relevant but there won't be
other potential issues that do come up
one of them and there are actually many
Muslims who are who are who practice
polygamy I mean that's a it's a it's a
relatively it's it's not that it's not
incredibly common but it does happen and
I would say that much of the time when
it happens it happens
secretly and the reason it does happen
secretly is just because of that the
social prohibition that that exists a
lot of people are just ashamed a lot of
women in particular they figure that
they think that their friends might
think less of them if they found out
that their husband took a second wife
and and those are those are really
things that have to do with the the
social norms in our in our own community
we're not necessarily proud of who we
are in our and our Deen and our
traditions and
and we were really so caught up in in
this particular culture that we don't
necessarily realize that that culture
might be harming us and it might be
harming our community in man it might be
harming a great deal a great many women
because those women as I mentioned that
example are you seeing this also that
this is a mercy for women women many
people think ok this is just for this is
something with the man you know how he's
created that's that's the understanding
is that it's just for the sexual
gratification of the man but that's
that's not always the case
there are several benefits for the woman
as well and this is an excellent example
that you brought up something that we're
seeing in the community where this can
actually be an avenue for many women to
actually get married whereas otherwise
they just have to remain single the rest
of their lives and they're just sitting
there and it's it's not an easy thing to
never get married your entire life women
also have needs they also have you know
emotional needs they have physical needs
and these are going to remain unmet for
the rest of their life because something
happened because they went and decided
to get go to medical school and become a
surgeon it just took too many years and
now according to their society they're
just too old for someone to marry them
and that's it you're done you waited
till the age of 32 sorry not likely and
we're going to get married
remains single for the next 40 years
this is definitely an avenue should
consider we're gonna win a hot topic
solution we're trying to save many
people from going in the wrong direction
keep it all pure keep it the way that's
pleasing to the Creator it's there are
we going to explore it talk about it
open up the topic that's what we're
doing here addy show
don't go anywhere right back you don't
want to miss out you want to be here
every Friday and then we'll try to give
you some short reminders in between but
you can't get that if you're not coming
back to the show every week Fridays will
be releasing it God willing inshallah
subscribe right now and enjoy all of the
content that we're going to be putting
out for you thank you peace be with you
so I'm like
back here on the Dean show with
attorney-at-law hamid sheikh mustafa
from the college of islam PhD scholar
chef xia in his book he talks about
let's go to the other side he says you
know why is this you know because we see
many of the people i know if you want to
call him there's some hypocrisy here
it's no good to the story of a man of
god who was allegedly caught in the act
pants down the pastor flow is said to
have been found in band with a woman
believed to he to be his church member
had a lot of people that's the bottom
line
the dirty laundry list goes on
representative Mark Foley and his
questionable messages to a male
congressional page Clinton critic Newt
Gingrich admitting he also had
extramarital affairs even current
presidential candidate John McCain has
skeletons in his closet he was still
married to his first wife when his
relationship with current wife Cindy
began one stupid mistake in the past few
days I've begun to atone for my private
failings with my wife soda my children
and my entire family I have exchanged
messages and photos of an explicit
nature with about six women over the
last three years there's no question
that I've done wrong did I take full
responsibility I did not have sexual
relations with that woman I am
profoundly sorry for all I have done
wrong just five months ago New York
Governor Eliot Spitzer was forced to
resign after reports of his involvement
with a high-end prostitution ring
they'll try to criticize the Muslim or
actually the Muslim is Muslims are
actually more monogamous did any anyone
out there people are practicing one form
of polygyny you know with their
mistresses you know they'll get up there
they're campaigning they got their
family even throwing the dog guys he
talks about and then next thing you know
there is some sexual scandal all right
pornography you mentioned this the
statistic so if you took all of the
Superbowl they read the revenue from all
of the you know Superbowl the baseball
all these major sports doesn't even it
doesn't even come a fraction of what
spent on port on pornography yeah now he
says he said why now why is this trying
to understand this he says [ __ ] but the
reality is very simple that man is hot
wired to be polygamous okay and he said
there's there there are if if they are
not to practice polygyny polygamy in
this correct responsible and ethical
sense of the world they will practice an
unethical form this pornography or
adultery form of a serial polygamy
involving mistresses and prostitutes he
also goes to back up so there are two
books to support this claim backed by
scientific we're all about now you know
religion is because science has become
religion now for some people he goes
back by scientific studies and analysis
one is sex in a dawn and another the
orange of sexuality by Christopher Ryan
and the one we have here a book he
recommends about Dave Marsh is the the
myth of polygamy monogamy the myth the
myth of Palach monogamy so basically
there's science now to prove that this
is just women might not understand it
but man is hot wired like this what you
think with it yeah I mean this kind of
brings me back to I read you know in a
book of tafseer which is a commentary in
the Quran by a scholar named Abdul
Majeed re-body he wrote an article about
you know polygamy or polygyny in Islam
and how do we explain it and you know
why do people have like a negative
reaction when it comes up and he says
whenever you're addressing the issue you
need to ask yourself three questions the
first question is is it natural the
second question is is it rational and
the third question is is it moral or is
it ethical alright and once you answer
these three questions you can figure out
you know what should I still have this
negative reaction or not and the first
question we're talking about it is it
natural so you look at it from two
perspectives the first perspective is a
historical perspective like you said the
myth of monogamy if you just look at
historical societies it's there's this
myth that many people have that it's
always been monogamous relationships
throughout history and that's just the
way it's been and now all of a sudden a
Salaam came and when the Quran came and
all of a sudden instituted this thing
about having more than one wife and no
one ever had it before that that's not
the case you look at ancient Egypt it
was practiced ancient Mesopotamia
a Syrian society it was practiced
ancient India it was practiced ancient
Chinese society it was practice the
Incas the Mayans every single major
society even the Hebrews
you know the Israelites right it's in
the Bible it's in the Old Testament you
have Abraham having more than one wife
simultaneously you got David you got
Solomon you got just numerous cases and
people just kind of either don't know
this or they just brush it off when it
comes across so when it comes to being
natural
we have a lot of historical press it's
something that's been practiced when it
comes to science and you know modern
findings and all that science has shown
that this this there's this perception
among people that men and women are only
physically different but when it comes
to psychological and emotional and the
way they process their sexual needs and
desires and all of that they're
identical
everything else is socialization and we
need to undo the socialization we can
solve the problem that's not the reality
the reality is I mean you just you just
look at it it's not even difficult to
see research has shown that men and
women's brains are different in the way
that they process information when it
comes to sexuality it's something very
similar you look at men they spend
billions of dollars looking at women who
they paid billions of dollars to just to
see women with very little clothing on
or no clothing on right you got Playboy
magazine you got the swimsuit when
Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Edition 's
you got strip clubs you got all these
things what you don't find is you don't
find any significant number of women
spending any money to see men you don't
make the opposite you don't find the
opposite pretty girl went out of
business with the others it's it's a you
just don't you don't find that I mean
you find just a few you know women when
they go to a strip club the goal is a
whole group it's kind of like a social
thing rather than it's not so much of an
erotic thing if they don't get turned on
just by just by looking at something
just by you know thinking about you know
I naked man or something like that so
they process information differently and
that leads to us having different norms
or different different ways in which we
experience you know people in which we
get turned on and different needs so
there's the aspect of whether this drive
something natural or not we can discuss
whether there's moral and ethical and
all that stuff but the first thing we
need to ask is it natural
it's natural historically and it's
natural even the drive itself is natural
then you got to decide to what extent do
you have to control it and if you don't
control it or if you don't find an
avenue to manifest it in in a pure
manner in a nice manner one of the
ramifications are going to be
ramifications are gonna end up being
these extramarital relationships you got
websites like ashleymadison.com
which has millions of subscribers now
they're trying to push themselves into
Asia they're trying to convince people
who are married that you know what
here's an avenue you can cheat on your
spouse with someone else who wants to
cheat on their spouse sign up to this
website will help you hook up and it's
it's a huge it's a huge business and
these are this is a major problem so
from the Bible from if you're a
Christian or practicing Judaism or any
other world religion from a religion
from ethical part of religion or moral
part is there any ground to say that
this is forbidden so there's actually a
chef Mustapha brought up a number of
historical examples of course that
that's that's absolutely true through
the world over even in the Americas all
Native American tribes actually wear
polygynous right however there's one
exception and that's ancient Rome and
ancient Rome and that's a big deal for
us ancient Rome you had one official
life you can have as many mistresses as
you want concubines oh yes yes
absolutely there is just today same
thing sure sure and but there was one
official wife who had the status and and
then we we got into the church the
church of course the Romans became very
very important because that's where the
church ended up becoming that its most
powerful its most powerful and our legal
traditions as far as this this social
norm of monogamy comes from not really
Christianity but from this Roman
tradition and that's what we are dealing
with and so when Muslims are often
arguing about how polygamy or polygyny
is Haram or stuff like that because I
hear these things from people regularly
they're often just they're often dealing
with social norms that came to us from
from
Rome not really from our tradition or
practically any other tradition in the
world so if you take okay from one
example this being a blessing of mercy
for women you have so many women who we
gave examples divorced widowed you know
so many men are dying in wars what are
you gonna do with all these women you
know what are you gonna go towards you
know they need their needs met also they
need a partner in life many end up
leaving their Deen their religion they
go up and maybe fall into promiscuity to
fornication right you need to eat yeah
and that's the second question so once
you answer what is natural is it is it
rational is the rationing it doesn't
make sense can there be wisdom in that
especially given certain circumstances
it may not be for everyone it's it's not
encouraged for each and every single
individual it may not benefit every man
it may not benefit every woman but in
many cases or at least in certain cases
it is it's very rational it makes sense
like you said what do you do in the
population is is not one-to-one what's
gonna end up happening is you got a
bunch of people and generally you'll
have higher levels of women populations
with Wars and all of that even
historically right especially
historically even if you argue in some
cases it's not it's not the case or
whatever it is nonetheless you will have
a not exact one-to-one map distribution
of male to female so what do you do in
that case the only other option is you
just leave them all unmarried
yeah and that's that's a major problem
in and of itself we're gonna go ahead
and take a break we'll be right back
with more guy willing here on the Dean
show subscribe right now and enjoy all
of the content that we're gonna be
putting out for you thank you peace be
with you so now Mike
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking about extending the family
families good right you want a bigger
family there's some sisters out there
who want any part of your family what's
wrong with making a family bigger can we
look at it like that now you have for
instance you look at the church let's
take this example you know the celibacy
thing for people who are in a certain
priest position we see that there is no
sanction for that by God there could be
but you we see what happens when you
close that door the natural way of
giving one example if someone has made
God has made natural the intimacy
between man and woman within marriage so
now you see some people going towards
another means right with these boys when
a station right what is criminal act but
now what happens here you closed this
door when the science is showing man is
hot-wired like this right so now what
does he go
he's on Ashley's here he's like a little
rat in a hole you know doing some
scandalous stuff you know these other
people are out there you know who the
hypocrisy they're following this this
what you say the Roman culture where was
like throw off the responsibility I have
my concubines I don't have to you know
fess up and be a man and take her as a
wife it's a lot of load of
responsibility right what do you think I
mean that's yet that that's a major
problem because we live in a very over
sexualized society you know you you just
you just drive down the street and you
know they're trying to advertise a can
of coke and all of a sudden you got a
woman with like a bikini on she's like
you're almost half naked or almost naked
why because they know men are interested
in that and when you go around and
that's all you see and you know women
are this you know make excessive makeup
and there's this whole beauty industry
and everything it starts to get to you
and if you're trying to you know protect
yourself you're trying to lower your
gaze and it's everywhere it you know not
being able to manifest or you know have
this sexual release is gonna have a very
detrimental effect you know even on your
health on your mental health and your
physical health and there needs to be
avenues where people can do this
lawfully you know as Muslims we always
talk about look there should be lawful
alternatives you know what okay we can't
you know we can't go to the nightclubs
we can't party we can't do you know
drink and get drunk and all that certain
things but there should be some avenues
to have socialization there should be
some Avenue some halal alternatives as
we say to be able to you know do
something which you know you just
fulfill the general needs like you know
recreation of socializing whatever the
same thing happens when it comes to
sexual needs human beings have sexual
needs if you close this door right and
if there if there's another halal door
that's there and it can be open and it
can actually bring benefit and positive
you know effects to the family or to the
individual or to both individuals then
this is something that we should be very
careful before we shut it and like Ahmed
was saying there's a lot of Muslims who
are saying that you know what this is
prohibited this is a thing of the past
Muslims better not try and bring this
back and these are Muslims who aren't
even saying this and that's very
problematic you know and and I
understand where they're coming from
they're coming from two perspectives one
is they're they're they think that
somehow morals have changed and looking
at this Roman framework and this you
know this Western values since
everything's monogamous we're gonna look
bad and things have changed the other
perspective they're afraid you said if
most if if you say that Oh Muslims can
do this they're gonna get in trouble
with the law
now it's against the law now we got a
major problem what do we do we don't
want we don't want Muslims we're not
encouraging Muslims to break the law
that's not the case at all so that's
where a whole and another variable comes
into play what do American Muslims do or
just Muslims anywhere where it's
technically you're not allowed to
practice it is there still a way to do
that yeah that's what we got experts
here a scholar an attorney I mean what
do you think now you have this dilemma
where the person is exploring this
option we see a lot of women also in UK
this has really talked about and you
have women who finish school they don't
want to be full-time wives they don't
want it they want to be you know someone
who's not having to be with her husband
full-time and this is something that
women are advocating and they're
actually coming we had who was it -
abuja is who came he said the women are
coming - they're they're pissed off with
the moms because they're scared to get
out and advocate for these women but now
they're scared that they might get in
some
has some ramifications right and part of
it isn't necessarily ramifications from
the law part of it might also be
ramifications from because of
Islamophobia and and that they might
their name was just going to be dragged
into the mud and people are going to say
things about them epic and and because
there is there is a negative perception
public opinion polls find this polygamy
is generally thought of as being far
worse than adultery generally by the
American public so and and there this of
course doesn't make any sense at least
not to me and probably not to you or to
Shiva but but it's just out there and so
so what we want to do obviously is
change the perception and we can't
really change the perception until we've
done it ourselves for ourselves as a
community as far as how people go about
doing it I do think that many people who
do go about with polygyny often do it
wrong they do it out of fear they do it
they maybe do it out of fear of their
own wife of their own family of their
own community and they'll go out in
secret right they might find two
witnesses they might get an official
efficient like ah but they're gonna go
out and do it completely secretly very
likely it'll be somebody who's
non-muslim who's completely out of
everybody social circles and those types
of things often end up in complete
disaster it's it's it's just the nature
of that type of thing it's an incredibly
risky type of activity it's much better
to be completely open about it if you
can be and I think in most every state
it would be it would certainly be the
case that you can in fact I believe in
every single state you can do it that
way even in the places where you have
things like common-law marriage and this
happens when you do something called a
cohabitation agreement and a
cohabitation agreement is is this
agreement a legal agreement it's not
it's not enforced by family courts
generally it's enforced in in civil
courts but it's been around for several
decades starting in California so there
was this case called Marvin versus
Marvin a man and let me just have a
contract
with each other an oil contract that
approximates marriage or it might
approximate the types of types of terms
that you would have in marriage but you
don't actually go out and get this
marriage and it might even have to do
with how property is owned I might have
to do with the rights that that the
spouses have are the respective rights
of the spouses and you can actually put
this stuff in writing and it's fully
enforceable in the courts and there
really isn't a limit to these
cohabitation agreements or what you have
now it's important to have them in
writing it's possible to do it orally
generally speaking however you don't
want to be in that situation because you
don't have any proof of what the terms
worth and so the best way to do this is
to have a contract and not to get
officially married in state court now
there is going to be some there going to
be some drawbacks to that necessarily
especially if there are people who are
wage earners they have benefits health
benefits things like that how do you how
do you actually navigate those sorts of
things or I mean it means probably
paying more bills you know if you are in
fact if if the husband is in fact
supporting multiple lives that's going
to be that's going to be a concern
however with respect to how property is
owned it's important to have that set up
in advance another thing is that people
get married officially for the first
time you know I'm in a I'm in a
community property state generally
speaking community property states
everything that you you earn through
your skilled labor and effort while
you're a married 50% belongs to your
wife 50% percent belongs to you you
can't really do that and have multiple
marriages and be equitable as between
various wives and so you would probably
need to not get married in the first
place not officially get married under
state law in the first place or have a
post-nuptial agreement that clarifies
property rights so that you're being
equitable with with everyone you also
want to make sure that
things like inheritance is covered
because unless you have an agreement
that specifies things and you know
you're taking care of you're taking care
of other types of ancillary issues like
like healthcare powers or inheritance
unless you're actually writing this
stuff down a second life is a legal
stranger and and with somebody who
really doesn't have any rights and
doesn't really it's like it's it's it's
like similar similar someone who just
doesn't know you at all and so you don't
want that situation either you want to
make sure that there's something that
exists that's enforceable a cohabitation
agreement specifically exists because
because people might want to get
together and there's some sort of a
legal bar towards marriage or they just
don't want to get marry a number of
other people have don't ever want to get
married because because they've been
divorced before they've been burned
before and the system treated them
really badly and they figure I'm not
really I'm not going through that system
again I'm going to create my own system
and and it's actually okay to do that
it's perfectly perfectly fine to find a
create your own system out of the reason
why people might do it in completely
monogamous contexts would be the elderly
for example people who are much older
and they still want to get married but
as we get older and get adult children
adult children tend to see their parents
and getting remarried as a threat and to
to address that they'll they'll not
officially get married and they'll get a
cohabitation agreement which is
something that that I've done before as
well for cute so there are there are
there are many contexts to this I would
I would say that if you do want to if
you are looking at something where
you're where polygamy is is being
considered don't go the official route
that will get you into into criminal
trouble it's also a legal nullity
because if you if you have a marriage
license you go and get another one and
and then you get married a second time
it's it's an old a few other things that
that do come up is when when you marry
somebody and you don't tell somebody you
don't you don't actually
tell another person that you don't tell
the other the other wife that there's
another marriage then or maybe there's
maybe the the second marriage wasn't
actually a official didn't officially go
through it just you know the paid there
was paperwork but the paperwork didn't
happen and the second wife thinks she
officially got married but but she
didn't and and the guy just deliberately
did that or hid that particular fact of
course that's bigamy that could be that
would be a crime but that would also
that would also the courts might
actually regard that as being a being a
legal marriage as well so you know that
that could come that could complicate
things at least as far as the as far as
the other spouse is concerned anytime I
talk to my Christian friends you know
brothers and sisters in humanity when
you when you go because the culture
today notice we're talking about
marriage something that the Creator
loves that it's an act of worship it's
something beautiful when I talk about
boyfriend and girlfriend and you know a
totally different realm some foreign
here we're talking about marriage and I
when I bring this up to people who are
becoming God conscious you know and they
maybe hasn't he the the guys you know
he's not Muslim but we get into this
area and he's I talked to some UFC
fighters and you know they got all the
women around them and usually they end
up falling to temptation they cheat but
when you give them this Avenue and they
want to do it's morally right right they
want to be right with God and then they
think I said man this makes sense you
know I like this you know if they're
keeping it real now there's the other
guy who's being fake and now he's like
what has come back this doesn't it and
next thing you know he's the guy who's
caught with the hooker in the car I mean
so this is something that is pure that's
in marriage that you know even they've
done they've asked I don't know where I
read this word the mistresses would you
rather be a continue to be a mistress
you know someone often it would work you
don't know about you forgotten you know
or would you rather be a wife you know
that title of being a wife is powerful
isn't it absolutely yeah
and you're being taken care of women are
seeking sugar daddies yeah yeah there's
a lot of women who are in circumstances
you know I mean they're in circumstances
where they would actually love someone
to take care of them you know there's
there's this women's liberation you know
kind of you can say feminist movement or
whatever that says women you know women
don't need to be taken care of or
something like that and they start you
know yelling these statements and all
that and okay maybe not all of them but
there are several who would love to have
a stable working man who is going to be
contributing to the foot nine and
contributing but taking care of the
entire family because in Islam the man
is responsible for the family it's not
like in many you know many of my
non-muslim friends
for example they share rent you know
their that even when they're married
they're married and the guy contributes
50% of the rent and the woman
contributes 50% the rent they go out to
a restaurant and they split checks right
in Islam a man is responsible for taking
care of the entire household financially
he's got to take care of the family and
there are many woman when they see that
is four even many Muslims I've come
across but she knew Muslims or someone
you know they've been divorced or
whatever it is they have kids now
they're like I don't I don't want to
work I have I have five kids and now I'm
divorced or my husband passed away okay
what am I gonna do I'm taking care of my
kids and at the same time you want me to
go work you know three four jobs or
something like that just to be able that
you know give them a basic they would
they would love to have someone to take
care of them and if it could only be
being a second wife I know dozens dozens
of women who would advocate for this but
it's that social stigma that we have we
got a limited - social stigma agree not
even thinking about one thing we didn't
touch upon as a topic of a zone to
children you having people having
relations outside about love what
happens there that's another element we
haven't even talked about marriage and
child is it's over moulded over 50% of
children are actually born out of
wedlock in many different states that's
the statistic of course what I would
advocate would be if I would advocate
cohabitation agreements then that would
probably go up but but at least with
respect to to Islam they're not they're
not illegitimate
at all I mean none of the Sahaba of
course went down to City Hall to get
married that wasn't like a thing in fact
even even in the the Christian tradition
I don't believe the the Catholic Church
even bothers to register marriages
themselves like this is the church not
even the government until like the 1500s
in the United States governments
actually started to get involved with
marriage more aggressively primarily I
mean there were two things going on one
is that they were they prevent and they
wanted to prevent they wanted to prevent
black black people from marrying white
people I thought was that was the that
was the that was the main thrust of
trying to trying to regulate marriage
another thing that of course happened as
as the Mormon Church and and that there
was a lot of polygamy going on there
were people that were there were church
elders that were marrying on a near
industrial scale and the government
wanted to try to put a stop to it and
and so we have this this regime of
enforced monogamy but but of course we
we still we still have the system now
where we have cohabitation cohabitation
is perfectly legal adultery is actually
not a crime anymore it used to be so
that would have been like in some states
is technically still on the books but
but even if somebody were to get a halal
marriage but but not register it that
could technically be adultery and of
course that's not something we need to
worry about the other thing is freedom
of speech where we have you know if I
call you my uncle and I can just go
around calling you say that's my uncle
but that doesn't necessarily make you my
uncle
you know so so just because you're
you're stating to the world that this is
your wife doesn't mean you're going to
get arrested for that and so those are
so it's actually quite it's quite safe
if you do it the right way I I think
it's I think this is all about social
stigma I think it's really just about a
culture that needs to be reformed it has
nothing to do with it has nothing to do
with the law okay we're out of time we
started with this again being a blessing
for women saving women and men to
falling into adultery losing their Deen
losing their their morality you think
you guys can start because there's a lot
of women tops
with a lot of your mom's like there do
you have that happening we do we do we
do women these are more given that there
are women as well yes yeah so what are
we gonna do now I think we I think we
really need more education in community
again what we need to emphasize and this
is like the disclaimer again it's not
for everyone and it's mainly for
Responsible men there are a lot of
irresponsible men who are just like you
know I just have the desires I just got
a fulfill it more and I'm just gonna go
ahead and take some more wife the guy
doesn't even have a job he can't even
take care of the first wife properly you
know so Allah does tell us in the Quran
that if you're able to treat them
equitably then you can do this otherwise
you stick to one and if you can't even
do that you should stick to zero because
you shouldn't even get married in the
first place right so it's very important
that we need to have proper education
the people who are responsible who've
shown maturity they're able to handle it
the women who are also responsible who
are willing to say you know what I can
handle this as well I can make sure that
we have a stable you know family in this
type of relationship they the Avenue
should be open for them and the people
who cannot handle it you should tell
them this is not something she just jump
- it's not gonna it's not a magic pill
it's not gonna solve all your problems
but at the same time we cannot close the
door to those people who are responsible
who can deal with it and we need to
learn educating the community and saying
stop closing door in everyone's face
because this is a potential it's one of
the potential solutions that we could
have to these problems of not being able
to get married to these problems of many
you know women having children and
they're not able to find someone to take
care of them it can solve many of these
potential problems okay thank you guys
very much
god bless you does Oklahoma makeup like
it set up subscribe right now and enjoy
all of the content that we're going to
be putting out for you thank you peace
be with you
so now Mike